economía aquí en directo a América
edición nocturna está con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches ahí turbulencias en la industria
aeronáutica colombiana el cese de
operaciones de viva Air creó un caos en
los aeropuertos de Colombia así es en
los aeropuertos de Colombia hubo
inclusive protestas agarrones y golpes
de parte de pasajeros que estaban
furiosos porque la aerolínea simplemente
suspendió operaciones y no dio ninguna
respuesta al menos unas 300 personas
también fueron afectadas en Perú otros
cientos en Colombia el Ministerio de
transporte el ministro de transporte de
Colombia Guillermo Reyes dijo que otras
aerolíneas estaban trabajando para
llevarlos a sus destinos Incluso el
presidente Gustavo Petro dio
instrucciones para que satina a la
aerolínea Estatal movilice los pasajeros
que quedaron varados la crisis de viva
comenzó con la pandemia y luego se
agravó con el aumento de los precios de
los combustibles a nivel mundial la
aerolínea de bajo costo espera una
decisión de la autoridad de Aviación
civil de Colombia sobre su propuesta de
fusión con Avianca que es la aerolínea
más antigua continente y la más grande
de Colombia que quiere comprarla viva
Air dice que la aeronáutica civil
colombiana que es el regulador aéreo
Lleva más de siete meses analizando esa
integración por cuestiones de
competencia y no ha dado una respuesta
Mientras tanto la aerolínea la
aeronáutica o civil colombiana argumenta
que si se fusionan tendrían el 100% de
la participación en 16 rutas nacionales
y es que eso afecta los términos de
libre Competencia por medio de un
comunicado también se conoció hace pocos
minutos que habían que suspenderá
temporalmente la venta de tiquetes este
28 de febrero y 1 de marzo la decisión
se toma con el fin de reacomodar a los
pasajeros de viva Air que se encuentran
aún varados en los aeropuertos
colombianos decenas de empleados de viva
marcharon por el aeropuerto de Bogotá
para defender la fusión y también sus
puestos de trabajo escuchamos parte del
ambiente
Hoy estamos protestando porque anoche
viva ya cerró toda la operación todos
estos trabajadores están en vilo y no
sabemos si van a continuar trabajando No
si viva no sobrevive todos ellos van a
quedar en la calle Sí con mi esposa en
el aeropuerto del Dorado en Bogotá
teníamos un vuelo a Cartagena a las 12
del mediodía Y ayer tratando de hacer el
checking nos enteramos de que la
aerolínea había fundido Aparentemente
quisimos hacer el check-in no pudimos
verdad toda la reserva no se podían
entrar a la página de Internet hoy nos
despertamos a la mañana vinimos a
averiguar bien Qué pasó y hasta ahora no
hubo mucha respuesta dejamos Colombia
Hablamos ahora de México porque el
presidente de este país confirmó que
tesla se va a instalar en la ciudad de
Monterrey en el norte de la república
mexicana esto después de haber tenido
una videollamada con elon musk bueno el
presidente mexicano aseguró que habrá
una serie de compromisos para enfrentar
los problemas de escasez de agua en esa
región de según el presidente tesla Se
comprometió a utilizar aguas reciclada
para el proceso de fabricación de los
automóviles eléctricos Nuevo León es la
segunda entidad que más ha recibido
inversión extranjera después de la
Ciudad de México el año pasado el atmos
dijo a inversionistas que buscaba crear
una mega fábrica de autos eléctricos con
una inversión que ronda los 10 mil
millones de dólares Se esperan más
detalles del proyecto este miércoles una
nueva planta en México se sumaría a las
cuatro fábricas existentes en California
Texas China y Alemania que según tesla
tienen capacidad de fabricar más de 1,9
millones de vehículos eléctricos al año
escuchemos parte de la declaratoria del
presidente mexicano
si van
a dedicar la inversión a México
y se va a establecer la planta
en Monterrey
y Mientras tanto en Estados Unidos
fueron presentadas las primeras
subvenciones para la fabricación
Nacional de chips bueno estos subsidios
enmarcan dentro de la ley de chips que
fue aprobada el año pasado por el
congreso estadounidense que prevé
destinar más de 50.000 millones de
dólares para reactivar la industria
Nacional de semiconductores con ayuda y
crédito para empresas el departamento de
comercio dio a conocer el martes sus
planes para empezar a aceptar la
solicitudes a finales de junio para este
programa de subvenciones eso sí los
beneficiarios que reciban más de 150
millones de dólares de financiación
directa deberán compartir con el
gobierno de Estados Unidos una parte de
cualquier flujo de caja o rendimiento
que supere las previsiones del
solicitante en un umbral acordado en los
próximos meses lanzarán una nueva
convocatoria para la instalación de
equipos y otra para la investigación y
el desarrollo en el campo de los
Microchips los proyectos seleccionados
podrán recibir financiación directa o
préstamos del Gobierno Federal unas
ayudas que deberán complementarse un
financiamiento privado esta ley es una
iniciativa del gobierno o de la
administración de biden que busca que la
fábrica de la fabricación estadounidense
supere a la de china en los mercados
mundiales Jorge Pues usted ya que está
mencionando a China justamente en África
en Kenia los comerciantes protestan
contra la competencia de China las
manifestaciones se dieron en nairobi son
contra la apertura A las afueras de la
capital de un nuevo pasar por parte de
un empresario chino los comerciantes ahí
consideren que ejercen competencia y
desleal por ofrecer precios por debajo
de la media del mercado organizaciones
de comerciantes kenianos se reunirán con
el vicepresidente del país para abordar
precisamente esta competencia de los
negocios extranjeros en el mercado local
china muestra un interés cada vez mayor
por África y se ha convertido en el
primer socio comercial del continente
con una notable influencia en el en el
sector de las infraestructuras Muchas
gracias Jorge por este resumen de las
noticias del mundo de la economía a
continuación ya viene el debate
[Música]